I had a good Thanksgiving I went to
Thanksgiving at Brendan shibez and
Brendan Schaub zhh is a man he does a
podcast he is a you know he was a
wrestler or fighter sorry
and he professional fighter and he does
a podcast called the fighter and the
kids and it's basically I think like a
foster agency sort of an he I don't know
if his he adopted you know it's like his
make-a-wish kid is actually more of a
senior citizen and the man's name is
Brian Collins
and they are teammates and their buddies
and Brendan Schaub has had me over at
his place for Thanksgiving and it was
awesome and he has a beautiful little
son and a beautiful little family and it
was just nice to see it's nice to you
know it's nice to be able to experience
somebody in a different element of their
life because it gets to give you more of
a fuller picture of them of those of
that person like when you see the post
office man sometime you see your mailman
you see him maybe smoking a joint over
by the bowling lanes and you're like
damn mr. [ __ ] you know mr. Randol he
likes to you know get blown out of his
mind and it starts to it give you a
better picture so now when your mails
late
you're not just like aw [ __ ] mr. Randol
you're like dang [ __ ] mr. Randol
probably somewhere give him blown out of
his mind or copping a couple grams and
that's why you know I'm not getting my
Amazon paper towel rolls that I ordered
but I went over to Brendan's child's and
they had and they had a nice time and
they had you know Brendan Schaub was is
part hispanic he's you know maybe 40 or
70 percent Hispanic or Peruvian I think
or something I mean look at him
the dudes who knows you know he's got
all kind of [ __ ] in it and he had they
had turkey you know Powell they had
you know corn you know corn salad
and they had also a some pies couple
pies somebody broke a glass and the ice
tray so you had glass and ice so if you
wanted to get a drink and make it cold
you taking a risk right there you might
[ __ ] two sips of dr. pepper cup I
could kill you if you get one of those
really sharp cubes that ain't even ice
boy that's not cold water
that's [ __ ] glass papa you know this
is violencia baby no we had a nice time
man and it was nice him to invite me and
him just made me feel welcome and and
that's something that can happen this
time you you can you can invite others
in it's not a wat like you know if may
third you invite somebody over to your
house for a snack they're looking at you
like you might be um you know a BTK
killer or a or a dangerous human or
somebody that makes soap at their house
or a real [ __ ] creep but this time of
you you invite people over it's more
normal it's more natural and so there's
just something very welcoming about this
time of year wow you know it's crazy as
my sister can't even read but what does
it have to do with us right now hope you
enjoyed that video and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one